Et soudain, elle pète.
Bonjour, je suis Lucien Maine, c'est ici que j'écris mes sketchs pour Golden moustache,
il paraît que vous avez des questions
pour nous.
Ça ils sont capables de le foutre dedans ces cons.
Première question,
A quel personnage que vous avez joué
vous identif...
"Rire"
Dans (euh) le sketch 'La pluie',
le personnage de la jeune fille
elle cherche un chevreuil et (euh) bah moi aussi.
T'es la femme de ma vie
je l'sais, je l'sens.
Mais, tu n'as pas besoins de courir le monde après ton destin comme un cheval sauvage.
Ça serait pas un personnage que j'ai joué, ça serait un personnage que j'ai écrit,
et ça serait Léa dans 'Les Dissociés', parce que j'aime beaucoup ce personnage,
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'en a fait Lolo
et voilà, j'aime bien ce qu'il véhicule.
Nous on prend soin des corps qu'on emprunte,
c'est pas ton corps, c'est celui de tout le monde !
Pense à ceux qui vont l'emprunter demain
- Ouais
- d'autant plus qu'il est pas à toi celui là, il est à Gwen.
On rend toujours un corps dans le même état qu'on te l'a donné
Sûrement Maxime dans 'E-buddies'
Parce que, en fait le personnage répond exactement ce que moi je répondrais
dans la vie, je pense,
à peu près, y compris
'va te faire cuire le cul'.
Tu dis de la merde, tu pense de la merde, t'es de la merde.
Mais ça va pas de me traiter comme ça !!!
- Je te traite comme je veux, t'es une connasse Sabine,
ah bah ouais, t'es choquée,
et pourtant je suis français, je suis
blanc, je suis trié sur le volet,
et bah je te le dis, t'es un connasse. Voilà hein
donc tu vas te cuire le cul avec tes idées de merde, je me barre.
Euh, nickel,
nickel, il n'y a pas de lieu c'est juste ce
qu'il faut
(Euh) Je pense Hulk, parce que (euh),
Hulk je pense qu'au début
les gens savent pas que c'est Hulk
ils le font chier, le mec il devient Hulk une fois et après les gens ils le laissent
tranquille toute sa vie quoi parce qu'ils ont vraiment pas envie de l'énerver
et donc je pense que
Bruce Banner c'est le mec le plus
au calme du monde.
Pourquoi Akim est le seul Arabe ?
Et merde !
Personne, personne ne le fait chier
tu tu tu
genre tu dis (euh), alors attends (euh) "je peux prendre la dernière part ?"
Le mec "- bah non, j'avais prévu de la manger moi.
- bah vas'y mange la, pas de problèmes."
Parce que le mec, c'est Hulk !!!
Quel a été votre parcours avant d'entrer au Golden Moustache ?
Bah tout simple je prend la ligne 8 jusqu'à Arts et Métiers après je descends et je vais à pied jusqu'au Trévise.
Moi je la trouvais bien.
J'ai fait des écoles d'acteurs dans Paris, et après j'ai fait
un peu de stand up, de la scène,
et (euh) voilà j'écrivais dans un blog ou je faisais un peu de blagues.
Blog - blague
Excellent blog et blague !
J'étais dessinateur pendant, fin, dessinateur et auteur de bandes dessinées
pendant six- sept ans
et (euh) après j'ai commencé à faire des Vines
et (euh) y'a quelqu'un qui a dit :
"Ha (euh) il est marrant et du coup on m'a proposé d'être auteur à Golden Moustache et après
je suis jamais reparti
parce que j'étais bien.
Et bah j'ai fait du stand-up avant et je
suis monté sur scène j'étais marrant,
on m'a dit : "Tu voudrais pas écrire des
vidéos ?" j'ai écrit des vidéos
et les vidéos ont plu,
on m'a dit
"tu voudrais pas rentrer chez Golden Moustache ?" et voilà.
J'ai commencé chez Golden Moustache, je jouais dans des sketchs
particulièrement dans les sketchs
des suricates dont Raphaël Descraques avec qui je jouais
dans 'Le visiteur du futur' donc Raphaël Descraques est le lien.
Professionnel en tout cas j'ai fait un
BTS audiovisuel, j'ai fait une licence cinéma
mais j'ai plus l'impression d'avoir
appris par moi même en faisant des vidéos en fait.
Et bien j'ai été au cours Florent, ensuite j'ai joué sur scène ensuite je suis entrée
à la comédie-française où j'étais
assistant metteur en scène puis metteur
en scène pendant huit ans
puis j'ai participé aux vidéos du
palmashow j'en ai fait 274 avant que
Flober m'appelle pour entrer chez Golden Moustache.
Quelles qualités faut-il pour travailler dans un collectif comme celui-ci ?
Alors il faut être bien sûr
drôle, il faut être travailleur.
- Mais après ce qui est important c'est
(euh) bah faut savoir super bien jouer, moi, c'est clair qu'en terme de style de jeu
je me situerais plutôt entre Depardieu et r2d2.
Il faut s'aimer les uns les autres.
Moi je peux vous faire plein de trucs par exemple je peux vous faire la tristesse.
Il faut être déterminé,
il faut être passioné.
La joie.
Il faut accepter
que des fois ça ne va pas
pas aussi vite qu'on le voudrait ou aussi bien.
Et attention ça c'est très chaud : la
mansuétude
Pourquoi Golden Moustache ?
Pour qu'on nous pose cette question,
pour toujours,
pour l'éternité de l'univers,
pour que le cosmos entier se pose cette questiooooonnnnnn !
Nyahhh
Y'a t-il déjà eu des relations sexuelles consenties au sein de l'équipe Golden Moustache ?
Mais, pas moi et je ne dirais pas qui c'est, tremblez !
Hein, toi derrière là, tremble.
Oui
Pourquoi tu précise "consenties" en fait ?
Parce que c'est bizarre de
de ressentir le besoin de préciser.
(Rire) On répond
non mais on répond quoi ?
On répond la vérité ou on répond ce que l'on veut ?
Moi je suis en couple. Voilà.
(Rire)
(euh) La première fois que j'ai vu,
enfin que j'ai tourné avec Raphaël Descraques on s'est masturbé face à face
en hurlant sous un pont
Donc, du coup, s'embrasser après, c'est assez facile.
Bah oui, y'a eu 'Les Dissociés'
(rire)
Pourquoi quand on fait caca, on fait pipi en même et pas l'inverse ?
Si l'inverse est possible.
(Euh)
"Pourquoi tant de sex-appeal, je ne comprends
pas dit nous ton" non moi non plus je ne sais pas
haaa ça bouge
(- T'as besoin de mettre ta main là ?)
- Mais c'est parce que j'ai peur
J'ai voulue faire une FAQ dans un endroit insolite
donc j'ai fait dans la grande roue
mais j'ai oublié que j'avais le vertige
Et là on est arrété et j'ai... HAAA
Bien sûr.
Voilà c'était la FAQ Golden Moustache j'espère que ça vous a plu, à bientôt.
Salut, c'est Lucien Maine
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et soyez également informé de l'existence du
'Lab' tous les vendredis à 18 heures
sur notre site
"Non, non, mais pas le premier soir.
Ok les gars, je suis tombé sur une meuf
avec des principes.
(- Oh putain)"